[Music]
howard doss
sean larkin man so we are actually in
las vegas still right now lost wages we
lost the wages there's a lot of loss
well you've been doing pretty well
actually i've been killing it and making
money i don't i was
i was waiting the other day just for
jason to come down and uh
sit there for i don't know 13 seconds
one 900 bucks that's fast lady came
around paid cash it was nice that's it
yeah i haven't put a dollar into a
machine haven't thrown any dice but uh
you buy a damn coke in the city you're
dropping like seven bucks yeah that's
it's pretty pricey around here yeah so
that's only money i've been losing but
we are here at crime con
parted with law and crime out here and
uh this is our second
second little podcast of the day yeah
man we've been busy today we've been
pressing the flash we have we have and
we've got a uh a guest a local guy here
we we chatted with gil a little bit
earlier
kind of a legend out of los angeles
worked on the nightstalker case we've
got a gentleman here for
i mean a historic
and i don't mean that in a great way but
a historic event you know here in our
country
um
one of the officers that was present and
i'm honestly really excited to have him
here because this is your favorite dude
you love the running gun cops you like
the cops that get with it that's it man
we so i i joke with howard
uh about this type of stuff he's into
the forensics and the minds and the
people that do stuff i'm like dude i
just like fucking cops that run and gun
man that's my thing i like guys that are
out there doing that we got a running
gunner we do so we've got ashton pack
who is now retired from las vegas metro
uh police department is that correct yep
here with us today so we are actually in
las vegas up in the i don't know
we're in the sky office we're in the
office we're in valleys yeah i'm not
sure what hotel we're in valleys all
right so we're doing this podcast a
little remotely yeah it's hey man this
works it works
but ashton as you know you've done a
little research yourself and our podcast
is called cocktails and cocktails
cocktails and cocktails and you are here
to provide the
the cocktails but you actually came came
correct and you provided the cocktail
when in vegas you know you always show
up with something you always bring a
gift so man
it's usually us explaining what we're
drinking so we're gonna throw this one
your way what are you drinking here
today this is a uh a jack daniels single
barrel select uh this is the vegas
knights edition and it was from the
founding year five
founding season five years ago and
while our season is pretty much over and
we will not be going on to the uh
playoffs unfortunately no pressure next
year nights but i thought i'd bring in
honor of an amazing team that was very
instrumental
in our city's uh healing process after
that one october attack
and you know that team really
really rallied around this community and
really earned their
their presence in our community
really quickly on this bottle uh it's
actually edge i mean which is a you know
rare that you see it says vegas born
around the neck
uh what's the
the etchings on the side here so that's
just the the low that's one of the logos
there the sword and the stars and the
other one is then actually the knight
with the v in it which is for vegas
and um i'm vegas born born and raised
here in las vegas very pretty unique
upbringing and who my parents were and
so i just thought it was very
appropriate for this uh for this
conversation well we do appreciate we'll
cheer cheers and then we'll jump right
into it
future guests remember this
take note
lovely yeah jack daniels is not does not
like to be considered a bourbon even
though it is
i think it's over 51 corn but it's it's
uh distilled in that lincoln county
method which is that charcoal filter
process yeah
we like a lot of the ncf stuff non
charcoal filter yes it's kind of a
little
got a little more bite on it a little
huskier yeah
yeah this is good though i mean this is
as far as jack daniels goes it's real
good it is we drink this every day
absolutely yeah i like the single barrel
all right so ashton man break it down
for us so you say your las vegas born
kind of took a unique road to get into
law enforcement or why you chose to do
so yeah my uh i was born here in 77 my
dad was a i'm a first generation
american on my dad's side he was an
immigrant from england
and he came here for howard worked for
howard hughes and then ended up working
in the casinos as a casino executive
and had a lot of friends there was
always an error mystery around my dad a
little bit of intelligence community
was the mi6 mi5 british royal marine you
know he also told a lot of tall tales
but he was this kind of larger-than-life
figure
always in a you know savile row custom
tailored suit working in the casinos and
taking care of you know in the 76 late
season oh yeah 70s
different era totally different world he
met my mom who's a showgirl
and so you know like casino executive
marries the show girl my mom ends up
starting her own interior design
business and designed hotels and
high-end homes here and
so i had this very unique upbringing in
this
house where my dad was a part of the
corporate side of pushing the mob out
and getting the mob out of las vegas and
testifying against the skim
so i always had cops and fbi agents and
cia people and all these unique
characters he's larger than life law
enforcement and intelligence community
men in my life who would show up and
give me a patch or a knife or a flag
and that kind of sparked my interest at
a very young age to want to become a cop
when i got older hey let's roll back
let's talk about the skim yeah
getting rid of the skin what was the
mafia skin here in vegas since we're
here well i mean the skim is just what
they stole sure and that never got
reported to the nevada gaming control
board under the state for the tax
collections and so in the movie casino
if you if you remember that movie i know
some of the younger generation don't
watch movies anymore it's crazy to me
youtube tick tock yeah i go youtube just
watch just youtube google watch casino
and when they raid that that casino in
the movie was called the tangiers that
was the stardust which is now where
resorts world is long gone but when they
raided the stardust they raided the
tropicana as well and also a downtown
property called the fremont which is now
owned by the boyd company and my dad was
the vp of the mint right next door and
they brought him over as the interim
general manager and they did the
forensic audits of all the books
and had to testify in district court to
the what the skim was how much was lost
to the the state tax coffers
and during when i was a kid little kid
growing up going to school everyone
always asked hey who's the big the big
tongan guy big hawaiian looking guy that
was 350 pounds but could run
across the field in two seconds like
what's he doing here and i was like oh
that's just my dad's friend he keeps an
eye on me and my sister my bodyguard
because my dad you know out of an
abundance of caution and knowing how the
mob was at that time in the 80s here
with you know the spilatro world and all
that stuff where cars were getting blown
up and
casino executives are getting whacked so
yeah
yeah absolutely hold that that is
actually this is probably the most
unique guy usually we have the path you
know i got in trouble as a kid i wanted
to
got the vegas homage sleeve started i'm
you know mom dad it's kind of a homage
to my parents so how far does it go it
goes up to the shoulder goes up here i
got the vegas sign on it oh yeah
that's some good words the killers uh
lightning bolt from their battleborn
it's just going to be like a nevada las
vegas you a killer's fan yeah absolutely
we opened the t-mobile the night they
opened it and i was there to watch them
and got a little bit close to backstage
and you know
didn't quite get a chance to chat with
the band but they're interesting guys
yeah they're and they're again they're
they were very huge huge pro vet you
know we love them here in vegas i know
they've moved on and they're living in
utah and other places but they come back
all the time and
there's just there's just such an
element to vegas to them that it's like
that modern rat pack to me that's
freaking awesome yeah and my kids love
it too because we used to play rock band
yeah oh yeah and then same thing
we had the drums and the guitars oh yeah
that was awesome we got that for
christmas one year for for my kids yeah
and uh my ex-wife uh the damn kids would
be sleeping they go to bed at night or
they were still asleep in the morning
she and i would be up playing i mean she
was on the drums and i played the uh i
played the guitar i couldn't play the
jumps for shit but i could do the guitar
i can't play a real guitar but i could
play the hell out of a rock man i play a
little guitar nothing too crazy and sing
a little bit but yeah i love the killers
i love that you know vegas for so long
didn't have it's become it's really
developed this art center downtown kind
of the arts district and it kind of is i
hope it breeds more of like the killers
imagine dragons all that las vegas
because there's so many talented people
here with all the strip shows and all
the stuff that's happening in our city
and i really love that you know i have a
good friend of mine i went to school
with since the eighth grade who's in a
local band and they're really great you
know and the local radio stations
playing them so i'm really i'm really
excited for what maybe is going to
emerge out of las vegas in the next 10
years as far as music and arts well
we'll switch it up real quick out of
music and arts and the nfl drafts going
on right now what are your thoughts on
that being a local guy and it's kind of
tying up the strip in the middle and all
that well that's that's that's fine
that's you know we do this all the time
this is this is a day that ends in y for
vegas yeah uh i was down there chatting
with some cop friends of mine that are
still on the job before i walked up here
and and you know vegas locks it down the
the las vegas metro police department
they're so used to running these huge
events 200 000 people come in town on
our weekends
like i said it's a day that ends in y so
you know fans and tourists i always tell
them they always ask me am i safe in
vegas i'm like you're as safe as the
choices you make and absolutely if
you're if you get pulled into if you
walk into an alley with a shady
character at four o'clock in the morning
to buy something you know you're asking
for trouble if you're walking up and
down the strip you're not gonna you know
99.9 percent chance everything's on on
the up and up here we have not only do
we have a sea of police officers but we
have an army of private security in
every single casino and they do a really
good job at keeping it safe and i mean
there's cameras everywhere here every
square inch of your casino floor is
under video surveillance yeah well
people come here to lose their fucking
mind yes they do and some of them do
yeah some guys can't handle vegas is a
constant thing i'm always saying that
the videos and the pictures i see
it's like no no you should just go home
yeah or just take it easy like have to
take it easy you know enjoy the sights
just have a nice little vegas boring you
know jack daniels
this morning i was walking out to get a
starbucks coming back there was a guy
had a a like probably a 12 pack of ultra
he was already drinking yeah 9 o'clock
this morning yeah yeah
man all right so ashton so
hear about the upbringing um
you start out here with vegas pd
directly or you start another agency and
worked your way over
moved up to northern nevada for college
ended up going through an academy long
story short spent three years working
for a kind of smaller
nevada sheriff's department in lake
tahoe nevada
kind of cut my teeth up there
and very much realized um
you know three years on the job i said
you know vegas is the center of the
universe it's the capital of the
universe and like i got to get home yeah
and for me it was like i felt like i was
on the like the tahoe titans triple a
ball team yeah you know and vegas was
the new york yankees i'm like oh there's
no way i could i could work there
all the self-doubt as a 20 something
young year old cop and
put my application in did the test did
the physical did all the stuff and i'll
send them like number 11 on the list and
i'm like that's going to be an academy
of 100 people i'm here i'm here like all
i gotta do is pass the background check
and i've already done that what
sheriff's department were you working
for up in tahoe douglas county douglas
county sheriff's department so it's it's
the carson valley and also the south
south lake tahoe south shore yeah the
south shore is a little bit rowdier than
north shore right yeah the the south
shore in california yeah it's it's we
used to call it ghetto with a view
you know
it's true the nevada side is very it's
very nice it's very expensive i lived i
actually lived on the south shore of
lake tahoe there on the california side
i had a sergeant
who let me move into this cabin it was
you know literally the size you know put
a wall here and a wall there it was it
was a small fishing cabin he knows how
you can stay there for the summer and in
the fall but there's no heat or no air
conditioning and in the winter you got
to have heat so you know come first snow
you got to move out so it was a summer
of 98 it was very interesting time in my
life when i was 21 years old and living
in a cabin one walk out the door and
there's lake tahoe and harvey's casino
and caesars and i'll trade with you
yeah it wasn't bad yeah that's a good
life for me and he didn't charge me
around i gave him i think i gave him a
hundred bucks a month no you can't do
that
so ghetto with a view i like that term
that's kind of your guys's hotel it is
jason that you guys are staying in and
sam who's here with us our producer and
these curtains that we have closed
that's uh where all the good hotels are
out there
in the near distance it's a nice hotel
yeah look oh
all right man so so during your career
in the police department uh las vegas is
a large apartment obviously yes a lot of
different things you get to move around
you know you kind of do three or four
years here you kind of get to bounce
around sure um
we'll build up to what happened back in
october of 2017 but just throughout your
career uh you know doing a little
research i saw all the different things
you worked in yeah including like jttf
and some of those other type of things
hold on jttf oh sorry we're speaking
police terms yes that's why i'm here fbi
uh joint terrorism task force okay cool
thank you for that appreciate it yeah
i'm sure well tell you what howard's
probably fascinating that i don't know
if i've ever explained it to him and you
were there for three years two and a
half three and a half years between
detective and sergeant okay yeah and uh
i mean las vegas i mean jttf in las
vegas is probably a little busier than
jttf in tulsa oklahoma probably um guys
i mean
it is what it is i mean guys with my
division you know we had a few guys
assigned to it as well for our local
deal so i'll let you kind of break that
down some of the stuff that you're
allowed to even talk about sure yeah and
so i spent a lot of my career i i did a
a good portion of time in patrol but
then i moved into the investigative
world i worked a little undercover here
on the strip
um there's a showgirl no never you're
doing that thing with it i mean one of
the ball-headed show girls flipping no
flipping uh no flipping the cards the
community cards damn it yeah a little
bit it was very fun it was a a unit that
no longer exists here in las vegas
called the tourist crimes unit and it
was one of those you know we had so much
fun that the executive staff said those
were oh yeah
i've been a part of those units ours was
called street crimes yes same exact
thing the the the the greatest fights if
i can even say that the greatest fights
because no one respects a hang badge and
guy wearing shorts and flip-flops but
you know i don't have my bat belt on i
don't have a couple inches of armor you
know the boots don't make me six five
out of six four you know it's like
you're in the flip-flops the shorts and
some gangsters are being gangsters and
we're like oh they're going to jail and
it was always oh yeah the fight was
usually on yep so between that it was
dope you know picking up the dope
dealers and the prostitutes that were
out there you know laying trying you
know trying to just victimize our our
good you know fun-loving tourists that
are here to enjoy themselves and not be
victims so i did a little bit of that
and then i was in the academy on 9 11
and so and i had studied political i was
a political science major i had a little
bit of an emphasis on many studies in
college i had studied all the world's
religions in high school i was very
interested in islam and all those all
that the arab world i was just
fascinated by it so 9 11 happens i'm
week three of my second academy here
with metro having come home now and i
kind of knew at that moment i had
already knew who al qaeda was no one had
even heard of them you know on september
12 2001 all of a sudden we had all these
al qaeda experts everyone's an expert
yep and um on facebook so i went there
and i just started to study and chip
away at learning as much as i could and
i with the ultimate goal of working the
counterterrorism world and and as you
know metro is a very progressive agency
and they were very quick to stand up a
counter-terrorism section they just kind
of took detectives out of the criminal
intelligence world and put them in it's
the same premise it's just a little bit
different in the in the nuance of how
you work your sources in your informants
and so i had always had a goal of
getting to that counter-terrorism
section and took years i mean years of
trying trying no no you're not ready
you're not ready no no worries i
understand i have to earn my i have to
earn my stripes and get in that unit it
was it was a vanguard echelon unit and
so i did some started out doing
detective work and next thing you know i
finally earned my right to get into that
unit and i i would like to think i went
there as a detective and crushed it you
know we i did every single
thing you can do in the counterterrorism
section i worked the day shift uh you
know suspicious activity reports which
back in post 911 world you know we got
some pretty weird like what what is
going on here like we have to peel the
onion back not a crime per se but all
those sars yeah sars yeah well hey man
vegas is a target if you want to knock
some people out there's a lot of people
here it's true it's it's a major
metropolitan area and like i s you know
like like we have this amazing community
but then we have this influx of 250 to
200 000 people every weekend yeah you
know most of our most of our visitors
are the southern california commuter so
yeah and what i tell people and what
what people don't really realize about
las vegas versus southern california or
some of our bigger metropolitan areas
las vegas is an island in the mojave
desert there is no resources there is no
one around there is nothing coming for
several hundred miles in any direction
and so vegas metro and the bosses that
run it i understand and because i've
been there and you have to lock you have
to own the valley you have to like like
we can't allow crime and terrorism
because no one's here if you're in lapd
san diego's an hour south you've got la
county sheriff's the largest sheriff's
department in the world you've got
national guard resources your coastal
you have the navy marine corps we don't
have those things here so like on the
night of one october when we had to
assume that we were not dealing with one
lone horrific evil man but i thought a
multiple-prong multi-cell terrorism
attack
that that's where the stress comes in of
policing this valley of keeping the
valley safe because we are this island
in the mojave desert
um
so after you get out of like jttf and
and we'll fast forward now just i guess
up to that day in october and i know
you've talked about this before and i
appreciate you being on here with us
talking about it
um
the festival that's going on at the time
i imagine just as you said the influx of
people that are here in the city a large
number of uh tourists guests and so
forth a lot a lot of officers out there
working the streets anyways whether
they're on duty or part-time gigs or
however you know you guys work it here
were you yourself on duty that night or
is this i mean because this this whole
thing
transpired pretty quickly yes and so it
wasn't like time for the swat team yeah
do you guys have a full-time team here
yes okay so um are are guys on duty 24
hours but essentially are they kind of
you know
not 24 hours but they're called mostly
okay yeah so and and that's it i mean
kind of like when columbine happened
that kind of changed the way police
officers responded to active shooters
period because before it was like hey
we're going to wait till the swat team
gets here to take care of this and
obviously you can't do that because the
number of lives that get lost sure and
same type of thing with what happened
here
it was you guys that were on duty the
boots on the ground at the time you guys
couldn't wait for you know for swat or
the backup or whatever to show up so so
basically what happened was many people
remember the terrorist attacks that
occurred in mumbai india i want to say
in 2008
yeah by a a terrorist organization
called let lashkar-itaiba and they're
linked to pakistani intelligence and
they came over in boats and they did
these multi-cell multi-prong attacks
throughout the city they shot up they
killed all these people in a jewish
center they laid siege to a hotel
and they had um they had communications
it was very advanced attack they had
these multi cells of people hitting here
hitting there and so they had all over
the city the police were very quickly
overwhelmed on top of the fact that
those cops had to pawn their ammo to
feed their family like that yeah one
thing i'll say about american law
enforcement is we will shoot back
because we have a lot
of ammo we will shoot back a lot yeah we
sure do so that night and in those years
after mumbai our department stood up
what was called mac tac which is
multiple assault counter-terrorism
action capabilities it's a fancy way of
saying how do we deal with the mumbai
style attack and what it was was it's
basically the basic premise
is every single area command in las
vegas has at least two squads working on
the slowest of tuesday night
one squad is the stay at home one squad
is called in the box so the in the box
squad is the is the squad that will
respond at the moment something unusual
extraordinary or some kind of a
multi-prong attack occurs in the las
vegas valley the stay-at-home squad will
stay and provide police services to the
area because we can't leave areas and it
tries to limit that resource over
convergence that we would see as cops
especially supervisors where you know 50
cops pull up and now fire can't get in
now the swat team can't happen it
happens all the time so on that night i
was i was a patrol sergeant i was
working kind of in the center part of
our valley
i was not at the event it was you know
my regular working shift but we were the
in the box squad and my the dispatcher
said hey uh call me and i could hear in
her voice something wasn't right
so i called her on the phone and we were
about to it was like 10 something at
night we're like graveyard will be out a
little bit we'll wrap this night up and
our week's pretty much almost over
and she says hey there's a there's a
there's multi shots fired at at the
route 91 festival and i'm like okay
we've heard you know i always we always
hear these 911 calls swatting calls
shots fired and i clicked the radio over
and i could hear auto what sounded like
automatic now no it's a bump stock right
and cops screaming people down officers
down
and my heart sunk and i i my heart sunk
my heart broke for my city because i had
spent so much time
in the shadows in the intelligence world
trying to stop stop something like this
from working sources and working working
cases developing sources of information
within our community that would provide
these kind of leads that would lead us
to an investigation that would stop
these attacks from happening
and my my mind immediately said this is
a this is going to be some kind of an
isis or al-qaeda multi-prong attack so i
rallied my troops
and uh
we i did the hardest thing i'd ever done
as a sergeant and that was not
rush off to mandalay bay because i knew
within that 15 minutes that it took all
my guys to get assembled
there was a thousand cops already on
scene there was a there was going to be
a swat element in route and i was going
to hit i was waiting for the second
attack the second wave attack to hit the
fremont street district to hit another
part of our city
and so for about 15 minutes i i i said
you know i had some very tough awesome
go-getter cops you know like pitbull
cops sure they were my real cops and
they were my five-year cops training my
i had trainees too so we were ftos but
there were only five-year officers
training i said it's like toddlers
training the babies yep and the hardest
thing i ever had to do as a leader on
the police organization was pull those
reins in and go we're not running quite
yet give it a second but nonetheless we
ended up down at the command post
it was pretty interesting because we get
there and that's when that i hate to say
fog of war i don't like to use war in a
civilian policing term but that's just
the term it's just this fog of confusion
that sets in when shots are being fired
people are screaming and emote you know
that amygdala hijack occurs the tunnel
vision sets in the adrenaline is dumping
and so we get to the the command post
which is actually just a little bit
south of mandalay bay
and someone got on the radio and started
screaming shots fired at the paris which
is we're right next door to it here at
the valleys they're actually considered
like they're kind of a linked property
in all reality
and uh my my watch commander goes you
know strike team 13 you go and i'm like
oh of course vegas i'm straight you know
lucky 13 you know here we go i remember
driving down las vegas boulevard in the
passenger seat of the car with my and i
didn't bring all my cops with me i
brought my most tactically proficient
many of them are now our swat team i
understand the other one i sent a team
to protect our trauma center because i
thought if we lose our trauma center we
lose the valley we lose the island in
the mojave
and so i remember driving down las vegas
boulevard that night and i was we were
pulling in front of the paris right out
here on on the strip and i was waiting
for automatic ak-47 fire to light my car
up thinking like this could be it so
this is amazing so in the period of 15
minutes from the time you get a call and
i assume you get a call instead of it
broadcasting over the radio because you
don't want to
cause a panic
because a lot of people civilians will
listen to police radios and find things
out but during this 15 minutes you
judicious in your decision process you
stop
you assess what's going on one of the
assessment things that you think about
is this could be a major event i need to
protect the hospital
fucking bad ass man yeah i mean that's
good thinking yeah well i just you know
our trauma center is
without it i mean it saved so many lives
so many cops have been saved by our our
we have two trauma centers here but umc
is the one that i always would say i
tell my trainees if i'm in the other
trauma center and i get shot put me in
the comments
over to the umc trauma center and those
people those those nurses and those
doctors there and not to disparage the
other trauma center i met one of the
i did a one october presentation with
the doctor who ran that night where most
of the trauma victims showed up over
down the street here it's called sunrise
a fantastic hospital i'm always
facetious they're great people there too
they saved a lot of lives that night
but yeah i just said if we lose umc
if terrorists run a v-bit into the you
know trauma center we
when that comes down you talk about the
hospital some hospitals have a lot more
exposure to that type of thing
there's a hospital atlanta grady
they send army medics there because
there's more gunshot wounds there than
they will see in a war zone yes so they
get to trade treat that so some places
are great at that stuff just because
they have the exposure to it it doesn't
have anything to do with the quality of
care just has to do with the exposure
that they say yeah and and so we at that
night and we we fly down to the paris
expecting shots fired and hearing things
and expecting the worst and
and what is what is happening is you
know i'm hearing someone say there's
been been a shooting and instead of
getting on the radio cool calm collected
i'm getting reports of shots fired at
the paris it's ah shots fired so
we we kind of park on the other side i i
know all the little nooks and crannies
from working undercover on the strip i
kind of know like don't pull in front of
this place pull around the corner and
we'll go into the sports book of the
paris so we walk into the paris all of
our you know rifles and kits and all
that stuff
and i see some lady gambling you know
with her shoes off i'm like well that's
that's good sign you know that's okay i
don't hear gunfire i don't see the smoke
alarms going off from the you know the
cordite in the air
and i remember i had to walk into i felt
bad i'll admit it i stole a bottle of
water from the paris
at seven dollars yeah they're like
they're like yeah seven bucks i need
water i'll have to come back and pay for
it
so but another team another strike team
we met kind of in the middle and i see
that sergeant and i'm like are you
hearing gunfire and he's like no i'm not
hearing anything so i knew then
that
i think we're getting a lot of this like
what we got echo reporting where someone
heard it's like the telephone game and
then we got the trolls all around the
world on the internet itself and
internet phones calling in fake
stuff to vegas
so i got back and i couldn't get back to
my command post so we kind of posted up
at tropon the boulevard
and that's where um i kind of posted
myself and that's where like i kicked a
certain celebrity poker player who who
are you talking about mr dan bilzerian
hey the security's boning out
[Applause]
jesus christ you need help
dude don't fucking you know better than
that i'm just saying
i just showed you my credit that's fine
i don't know who you are keep moving
keep moving let's go
let's go
i've heard of that guy he's a nice guy i
actually like dan i listen to him on a
lot of stuff but yeah i looked over i'm
standing there with my rifle and and
we're uh we're trying to safeguard the
triage center we set up a hasty triage
for the paramedics and fire
and i look over and there's clearly a
deceased human being with a a a a cover
he's covered with a sheet
and i look and i see this guy and this
buddy of his are like picking the body
up and i thought he's wearing bdus and
i'm like why like why is medical
trying to load this dead body into like
we don't we don't move dude that guy's
not going anywhere yeah right you know i
like unfortunately he doesn't need to be
triaged no does not yeah he's and he's
on the tarp that is like
nothing we can do for these folks this
color is there's nothing we can do here
and i look
and i'm like that's dan bilzerian so i
walk over to him he's he's hot is he a
las vegas native or is he just happen to
be here
a lot i think he's got some he's got a
lot of business stuff going on here i
think probably with his poker world okay
and i i see him i said mr bilzerian sir
what are you doing and he goes um we got
to get this guy to the hospital man we
got to do something
and and i appreciated it i said listen i
really appreciate
and he truly did i could tell in his
heart he wanted to help and he i think
he asked you guys have any extra guns
we'll go do i go the best thing you can
do for me right now is be a good witness
and head back to your hotel room and so
that you know that was my and then i had
a picture of it it showed me on the news
and you could see him i don't think the
news figured out it was him but but i i
had to have him and his buddies removed
out of the crime scene
and then i ended up taking our team
found out that thousands of the people
who had fled from the event kind of ran
north and into the tropicana hotel
so i ended up going into the tropicana
with my team and find it finding out
that thousands of people were back there
most of them under the influence they'd
been drinking all night
and you had those you know one lady
very unfortunate
just very and very distressed very
distraught
had blood and and brain matter
and said like her loved one had been her
loved one had gone down and she didn't
know what was going on and there was it
was she was covered in it
let's get her to the hospital you know
let's get her the help she needs
and then the the drunk guy who's like
i'm gonna kill him give me a gun and
he's trying to rile people up i'm like
let's get him out of here and then i
just grabbed the bullhorn because i just
kind of figured these folks need to hear
something from a leader in the position
of government to go i'm really sorry
that this happened
at the time i didn't know
the total number of loss i knew one of
my officers i knew one of my partners
charleston hartfield had died at the
festival uh kind of sprung into action
you know as many many off-duty cops
tonight and many civilians just absolute
heroic people
so i just addressed the crowd you google
my name you'll see my body cam footage
that is you know out there on the news
the crowd has given us you know clapping
for us and you could you could tell
they're very appreciative and finally as
we started to think and then i see a guy
before i got even gone on the trip
account i saw a guy that i'd worked on
the fbi task force with
and i run up to him and i go was it al
qaeda is it isis what is it he goes some
dude from mesquite nevada
i couldn't believe it
just blown away yeah you know i know we
kind of joke about you know dan being
out there and that's been out in the
media before and you're talking about
you know some of the other civilians
that are wanting to stand up and do
something and obviously civilians are a
huge role in for us in law enforcement
but you know just doing a little
research about this incident out here
and there were a lot of civilians that
received awards for different things
that they did out there i mean there was
a british shoulder a british soldier
that was here for it a navy pet petty
officer a detective from the rhode
island state police that happened to be
there part of the crowd
an assistant scout master that was out
there um and then and then a sergeant
with the uh utah army national guard and
these guys either helped evacuate people
um you know they didn't panic and what
was going on people that were they were
helping treat people for injuries and
things like that so when you have
something of this mass quantity
with thousands of people out there and
obviously the number of injured and
deceased
and you guys are still doing the job you
guys have to do it does take people like
that that are out there
and oftentimes it's people you know
howard you're a nurse you know i'd like
to think if you were at the scene of one
of these type of things you're going to
stand up and start doing nurse shit
medical shit i would do nurse shit you
know what i mean though but it's like
you said
stuff like that so the the the part with
the dan it is a big joke it's been a you
know and i don't mean it in a negative
way
but
we are grateful for those that do have
training and they can help in those type
of scenarios there were there were and
mr bilzerian was a he was very kind and
classy to me and he was just very upset
about what had happened i could tell
from the bottom of his heart that's a
he's a good dude absolutely i've never
met the guy outside of that night but i
you know i know he's got a reputation
yeah so you look at his instagram or
social media it's a little bit different
he's good in my world but there are
people that night that did far more
heroic things than me i there was a
i did a presentation in san diego a guy
comes up to me goes i was there that
night i got shot in the head i was a
southern california police officer i go
come back at the end of my class you
know i want to honor you in front of
this crowd yeah come to find out he's
there with his fiancee
he gets around in the back of his head
it kind of blows the skull cap off and
he just goes down
she the the wh
his fiancee now wife who's a dispatcher
very you know very situationally aware
people absolutely she knows immediately
he's been shot
she puts the skull cap back on his brain
and she gets shot twice through the
chest geez and she goes down and she
turns to these cowboys and says my
husband's a police officer get him out
of here
like what a hero so i hear this story
and he came to my retirement barbecue
his name's mike gracia he's a fantastic
guy
he's fully recovered she finally ends up
tracking his phone to sunrise
with a chest compression for through and
through gunshot wounds
and she finds a nurse and hey is my
husband alive and
you know the nurse doesn't pull any
punches it's not very very very unlikely
your husband's going to survive yeah but
he made it and the whole time she's like
okay cool calm and collected no no no
amygdala hijacked no panic
just take a breath and carry out the
mission right there'll be a time for
that you know if would i be able to do
i'm like okay we responded that night
but like
you know like i had body armor and a
right ar-15 and it's like we have all
this equipment i'm not drinking a
whiskey at the concert and i take a
round right right and she saved his life
and then i get to meet their newborn
baby that would not be alive today had
he not survived wow so i i'm like that's
why i do these talks this is why i talk
about one october it's not about me it's
about the people right who lost loved
ones the amazing
heroes of that night who were in that
crowd the cops that sprung into action
the firefighters the cowboys
my favorite stories a lot of people ran
a lot of folks jumped the fence into the
executive side of mccarran airport yeah
i'd say exactly people ran towards the
airport in true cowboy fashion they got
into some of the planes and drank all
like one planet
one one plane had like a bottle of pappy
van winkle gone gone you know like i've
never heard of that is that good stuff
that's one of those little inside you
know you don't get that in the after
action report so yeah yeah well and just
talking about the people out there as
you talk about the victims i mean there
were
and if my numbers are correct please
incorrect please correct me
61 people died
60. 60 died okay
um 58 died 60 within several years
correct yeah like people that suffered
uh gunshot wounds out there that died
right as a result later then there could
be a 61st who is
like i don't know maybe it hasn't hit
the news yet or not okay
so so roughly 60 people died from it um
411
injured by gunfire 422. okay 422 people
injured by gunfire i mean seriously
think about that but he was shooting
some big bullets
but another roughly 450 people were
injured just in the ensuing chaos
whether you know i mean sprained ankles
whatever you want to talk about you know
450 additional people injured but you're
talking 400 and 11
gunshot victims
not counting another six he had died i
mean that's just absolutely
mind-boggling but when officers got up
there to his room uh which was on the
32nd floor of the mandalay bay
he had obviously killed himself
inside the room they found a total of 24
total guns majority of them rifles
and
he was shooting
he had used a hammer to bust out a
couple windows so he could start
cracking rounds off down at the crowd
and it was something like i think i made
a note here on the distance he was
shooting
i mean it was something uh
oh 490 yards away
well from uh you know an advantageous
position and you know a position up in
the air
just down on helpless people 490 yards
away yeah five football fields it's a
waze yeah yeah he had a mix of those you
know the two two three rounds and those
but it's the 308 rounds that reach out
and touch touch folks
and um
he had tried to shoot the uh
the fuel tanks the fuel tank out of the
airport fuel tanks which you know didn't
it didn't work thank god
but
the um yeah a ton of guns and i i'll
give you the inside baseball that that
no one really knows about from that
night
as far as i i'm very hesitant to use the
word miracle
because if you lost a loved one that
light that night there are no more
miracles in this world and so my
my heart breaks for those victims and
their families but if there was any
shifting of the energy in the universe
that night
he had that suite and then he had the
side room next door to it
you know how you can do the jack and
jill doors right
and he had had a lot of his heavy 308
guns laid out on the beds in that side
room
and when he went in there he put all the
guns on the bed and he put the key card
to the room down
he went into the suite broke the window
or broke the window in the one room
broke the window in the suite and as the
air
drafted through caught the door and
locked himself out of that side room
so locked himself out of the
quote-unquote armory the real big guns
yeah what we uh what we probably
guesstimate uh that he was going to use
to try to ambush our swat officers
and so um you know i like i said i don't
want to call it a miracle but if there's
any
anything anything positive in in the
energy of the universe that night it was
that that just a little bit of physics
and that wind
shut that door on them
well so
you know this podcast isn't here to give
this guy's name out there and give him
yeah
yeah exactly i mean this guy and listen
it is uh it is still one of the
mysteries in law enforcement to this day
i mean unless you know something we
don't know uh it's still a kind of an
unknown on why he did it i think the fbi
or atf they've kind of closed the case
up they don't they don't know exactly
why he did it this guy wasn't like a
career criminal uh he'd only been in
trouble for traffic citations before and
he was what 60 years old roughly or so
like that so this this wasn't some guy
who
you know we don't know why
but
you have since retired from the police
department i have and you have kind of
um out there still doing amazing things
basically and talk about this hope for
prisoners that you're involved with well
i you know i was originally going to get
my private investigators license as so
many retired cops do and or start a
podcast where you can drink and talk to
other cool cops on it that might be on
youtube yeah come on you're pretty good
you're pretty good at this um you know i
do i have my own company it's vanguard
intel group vanguard intelligence group
and that was originally going to be my
my pi world in consultation and training
but i had been a part of a cadre of
volunteer mentor police officers that
metro had partnered with this non-profit
that focuses on prison re-entry
and basically the idea is is so the
organization is called hope for
prisoners and it was founded by my now
boss a fantastic human being named john
ponder john's kind of a preacher he's a
pastor i always had the heart of a
comedian he's at the heart of the pastor
and so
yeah
and so he uh he went to federal prison
for bank robbery
and finds god in prison and kind of
turns his life around and when he gets
out he strikes he creates a good
friendship with the fbi agent who
arrested him and he is in communication
with a federal judge who put him in
prison saying i'm going to change my
life i'm really going to do it federal
judge you know takes some leniency on
him doesn't put him away for as long as
he easily could have
john gets out of prison comes back home
here to las vegas and sits down with a
visionary law enforcement leader here in
las vegas i'm
my mentor a guy named kevin mcmahill
who's running for sheriff here he's a
retired undersheriff
mcmahiel kevin mc yeah vote kevin
mcmahill please
um and anyways kevin and john i think
kevin oftentimes was a captain you know
and he sat down with john and kevin's
visionary you know he sees he sees the
world through a different lens and he uh
they came up with this idea of bringing
cops in as part of the solution not part
of the problem in prison reentry and so
we started going into these sessions for
a couple hours you know on the thursday
of the session and just humanizing the
police the police officer the badge the
uniform it's like we're not robots we're
not we love that shit that's why we do
this podcast yeah and it is and and i
have cops that come in and give stories
that are so horrific that i'm like how
did that cop not end up in prison right
and what i find with with our people i i
don't call them ex-cons anymore i call
them you know formerly incarcerated
individuals
they are
they easily could have been cops they
easily could have gone into the law
enforcement soldier warrior class and
there's also vice versa i wanted that to
catch you off i've had this conversation
there are guys that happen to be cops
that could have been easily on the other
side and i know shady caught we all know
shady well i don't mean necessarily
means shady i mean
you know cops yes i know what you're
talking about but i'm saying
integrity's tough well my where i grew
up at in the bay area and we had we had
a guy on on our podcast by the name of
marcus timmons and he was a kid that i
grew up with at the same time
we ran around each other
and he ultimately ended up doing a bank
robbery he was a gang banger he was
selling dope he actually did porn for a
little while too but it was like we've
been together i mean all these things
and he's been on our podcast and that's
and that's one of the things we talked
about is like dude you could have
flipped this for either one of us yeah
he could have been the cop and i could
have gone that route
i probably wouldn't have done porn but
yeah but
you're
i'm good looking but i don't have that
you know
you know that thing out there so anyways
and so
i had been a part of this cadre of
police officers that would come in and
tell their stories and kind of you know
we don't want to lock you up we don't
want to take you to jail right we see
the system does we know there's tweaking
that needs to happen in our system and
long story short what do you need from
us you know we're not here to lock you
up we don't want to do that short of
public safety threats you know what i
find now is we we're able to
you know the guy has an addiction it's a
drug addiction it's an alcohol addiction
he falls off the wagon we can get him in
a sober living we can get him into a
rehab facility i don't have to take the
easy route and drop them off at county
jail now i tell them this is hope for
prisoners not hope for no prisoners
public safety issues will be addressed
number one and there's always going to
be prisons there's always going to be
people who do horrifically evil bad
things in the moment doesn't necessarily
make them horrifically evil people they
just made horrible choices and then the
police are going to show up and
investigate those crimes and hold those
folks to task but the bottom line is
when they get out and 95 to 98 of them
are going to get out
what are we going to do with those folks
give them 50 bucks and a pat on the back
or bring cops into the room make them
realize that the police and them have
things in common far more than they have
different including where they came from
the idea that we're not going to arrest
our way out of these problems
on top of several other things and then
build relationships and build rapport
with those people and then they go back
into their communities and say hey not
all cops are bad
you know they're not all bastards and
just i mean this is at a much simpler
lower level of that but you know working
in the gang unit forever dealing with
gangsters and it's the same type of
thing we'd sit and talk to these guys
whether it be sports or dude i would
trade
you're gonna laugh at this my xbox
handle with guys yeah and they're like
you man you play xbox i'm like yeah dude
let's play call of duty man i'll you
know i'll fuck you up with some c4 or
whatever it is you know hardcore that's
always what i'm saying it's like it
would help them go man this dude's a
regular dude that just happens to be a
cop yes my job is policing yeah my
passion is serving
you know like and and and what i find is
there's there is so much energy in folks
who are coming out of jails and prisons
when they really truly flip the switch
and they really truly want to change
their lives and we're there to help them
along that we put them through like an
academy it's like a workshop it's 40
hours but then we bring them back for 18
months of follow-up care where we give
them a case manager we give them a
mentor and we push them to their goals
what is your vision where do you see
yourself in a year where do you want to
be i want to be i want to own a michelin
star restaurant let's get you into
culinary classes i'm sitting on grant
money right now i want to go to cdl
school we'll write the check you want to
learn how to weld we'll write them the
check we're doing job fairs we have job
partners we find that a lot of
employment people here in the valley in
las vegas they're so caring and they
give back and they're like i don't mind
hiring somebody who's coming out of
prison if they're willing to work hard
and and follow the directions they just
don't want to hire a project well
especially here right now with uh you
know post code a lot of people got
you know not this isn't on the political
side of things but a lot of people have
gotten
uh used to free checks from the
government they don't want to work and
man and that's it employers businesses
things like that it's like dude if
there's somebody that wants to work man
we'll show them the way we'll give them
we'll give them that opportunity
regardless of what their history is and
you know there's a lot of talk about uh
you know people that going to college
but man
plumbers electricians you know all these
type of things trade schools i'm telling
you man you you know you can make a good
living you're not looking over your
shoulder worrying about the police
you're not looking over your shoulder
worrying about you know
a rival gang member or a dope dealer or
somebody trying to rip you off and you
can make a good living and take care of
your family and live a normal normal
life by doing that we had our awards
annual award ceremony last night and we
highlighted
five of our former you know rock stars
who have gone through our program
ranging between five and 15 years in
prison
they got out
they said if it wasn't for hope for
prisoners i don't know what i would have
done i can't believe that the police
were there to help me and support me and
pat me on the back what's amazing is we
have our law enforcement session that we
come in with i bring in my cops and some
of these young cops you know they're
they're kind of voluntold like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you kind of go do this
thing today and they come in and it's
kind of like the opposite of fight club
if it's your first time talking i you
know first time here i don't want you
talking i don't want you to stand up
but i go you know i don't want to talk
i'm you know what is this thing oh you
just sit there and let the magic happen
because i get the same thing with the
folks who are formally incarcerated they
get in and they're oh the cops are up
here some of them are shaken
and by the end of it by the time we get
up and a couple of us give our our
speeches our spiel
i've got people with tears in their eyes
hugging police officers who never
thought they would even ever fist bump a
cop right there's some great community
policing on the backhand you know i mean
you you put them there but you got to
help them when they get out as well yeah
well you know what we're out of time
yeah we so ashton man uh where can
anybody
get a hold of you follow you you know
check out hope for prisoners where they
want to donate whether they know
somebody who maybe could benefit from it
and so forth hope for prisoners is you
google hope for prisoners you'll find
the website it's hope for prisoners.org
we need money or mentors i need men
mentors i don't care where you're at in
this country take our online training
we'll assign about an hour a week via
zoom via facetime whatever that looks
like
of course if your local las vegas will
take you as well i really would love to
see more law enforcement retired and
military community because they kind of
know how to call bs when they see it and
push guys along that path
me personally you can reach me i'm
ashton hope for prisoners.org
if it's police related law enforcement
training consultation it's ashton
vanguardvegas.com which is my business
and then i'm on twitter at ashton pack
ashton
p-a-c-k-e and i think my instagram is
ashton underscore pack all right one
last question so hope for prisoners is
not just a las vegas deal this thing we
are looking to expand we want to move it
into other parts of the the country
because the model is so so it makes cops
safer and it's so effective and what we
have a 94 success rate that's the lowest
lowest recidivism rate of any prison
re-entry program in america we have a
sister organization i want to say it's
in minneapolis
minnesota okay um we've gone to some
other jurisdictions you know the
i don't get the buy-in from the
executive staff there okay but that
comes down to police culture you know
their policy says oh we're a
community-oriented policing department
but their culture you know your culture
says otherwise for breakfast yeah yeah
yeah so but you know i'm not mad at them
they'll they'll come around and see the
light soon enough all right we're ashton
man we do appreciate it oh yeah cheers
cheers thank you so much to vegas thanks
man
[Music]